Derrick what do you think about this?
>> So what we talked about before was
that the bottom layer
is the hardware layer.
I'm not completely sure what
the hardware of Watson looks like but
I assume there has to be a physical
computer there somewhere.
At the next layer, the algorithm layer,
Watson has some general searching and
decision-making ability that allows him
to search over his knowledge base and
come to decisions.
These are general abilities that
are separated from whatever
individual thing he's trying
to think about right now.
And then at the top layer we
can think about exactly that,
what he's trying to
think about right now.
So the task here might be
answering the inputted clue.
This would involve searching on
the individual information in the clue,
processing his knowledge
specifically about that data,
and then coming to an answer
specifically for that clue.
>> That was a good answer David.
So the again the three layers and
note that in the task layer here,
answering the inputted clue,
knowledge is also a part of it.
Knowledge that Watson must
have in order to be able to
answer that particular question,
how that knowledge is implemented,
what kind of presentations it
uses goes in the second layer.